yes i'd swipe right on that tinder
profile
let's serve up some news sunny side up
ancient women were hunters too this
makes me have to stand up i can't even
take it
usa today reports that archaeologists
are making a big correction
because they just found the 9 000 year
old remains
of a prehistoric woman buried
with her big game hunting kit
to you and me it looks like a bunch of
cool rocks but
to the ancient huntress these tools
can slay a mighty beast i'm so excited i
just think that's the coolest story
women hunters i can now smell like a
book
all the time thanks to a new perfume
from
indie bookstore powell's books i
actually was lucky enough to get to do a
reading of the book i wrote called
wildflower there
the sight scary mommy reports that the
limited edition unisex scent
is described as invoking a labyrinth of
books
secret libraries and ancient scrolls and
cognac swilled by philosopher kings
i want to smell like that yes i'd swipe
right on that tinder profile
hot for books hi drew
how is your morning so far always early
bird
well my day is going great here on
sesame street and
and you know the old saying the early
bird gets the birdseed
yes it does yes it does i'm tongue-tied
because i'm so excited
to meet you i have love i'm excited to
meet you it's a dream come true
and today is world kindness day
do you mind explaining what it's all
about
oh sure well i can tell you what
kindness is about
you know kindness is about it's about
showing people
how much you care and and and you can be
kind to
to animals and and the environment too
and
and it makes my friends feel good when
i'm kind to them
so so that that kind of makes me feel
good you know
our next guest is the mother of two and
she created a line of masks for the
whole family
from supermodel to supermom please
welcome
karolina kurkova being moms we knew we
wanted to create masks that really were
happy that were fashionable that were
fun and different and really
make it a little bit more fun and easier
for people to wear them especially for
children you know how do you tell a
three-year-old oh
now suddenly you have to wear this mask
and so we really worked really hard how
can we make them more comfortable how
can we make them more fun and
so we did embroidery of cats and a dog
which is
our cat kaya and doug bowie and we gave
it also a story to kind of turn this
mask wearing around from being something
that's like
so hard and difficult it's you know what
you are a superhero and even superheroes
don't just wear capes but they wear
masks to protect the people that they
love
i'm really excited to announce a
collaboration i'm doing with domino
magazine
one of my very favorite magazines
obsessed
i even got to be on the cover of the
very first issue of domino kids
with my girls and it's their first kids
issue ever
and i recently just launched my own
pinterest page
but i'm proud to announce on it there's
a collaboration
on the board and it's domino kids ex
drew barrymore
here are some pics that's actually my
pool house um
and i just really love kids world and
kids rooms we have flower kids flower
homes
these are some things you'll find on the
board there's also some really
imaginative inspiration for bedrooms
that's me actually holding jonah's
flower pillows
and the beautiful blanket he knit for me
[Music]